here we go there you are
all right we are living in my ears
he's here
all right hey welcome back everybody to
the 120th
corridor digital podcast
i think 121st i think
137.
it doesn't matter anymore what matters
is that we're all here and this is the
christmas special and sam and i wanted
to start this off by challenging one
another to a christmas carol
on guitar so sam do you want to start or
do you want me to start with these
ferocious practicing
we've got okay people to entertain over
the we gotta tame people these holidays
[Music]
on a classic
green sleeves
classic
[Music]
did we say classic yet
because it's a classic
jake said classic did you know that
that's all i'm playing
are you ready are you ready to hear mine
here
you're about to you're about to witness
it
okay are you ready attainment
[Music]
is
it's like the dc extended universe
jake has a gift
[Music]
something about that that was beautiful
wow odorous thanks guys
i've been working on that for the last
five minutes
[Music]
and i gotta say
you know it turned out that it turned
out great
say i'm still bringing the heat though
this is a contest i'm just saying
i mean he's sleeping in heavenly peace
over here you know hell yeah dude
[Music]
there you go beautiful wow beautiful
i'm in the spirit i'm in the spirit of
christmas
all right so it's our last week here at
quarterback me there yeah
this is it guys this is the last week
after this we shut down the studio
forever i hope that you've enjoyed it
and it was nice knowing y'all and
there's no chance to rehire
peter ever no
it's over peter's gone
we're actually we're shutting down the
studios so that we're never put in a
position where we have to re-hire him
and then we're all threatened by him
really it wasn't you know good for yeah
and especially a studio that has zero
history of ever making any jokes about
peter no yeah ever
[Music]
everything is 100 i want to just quickly
point out that we were nominated for a
streamies award for best visual effects
and guess what
we didn't win
oh no that went to zachary kingonitis oh
beautiful i feel like at this point
though i feel like at this point all
they do is pick the same like batch of
channels every year and then just like
pick one of them
i don't know i was kind of hoping we'd
win but at the same time we've won
enough yeah am i all right
winning gets old
you know it's hard being at the no i've
done
um but we've also kind of deviated a
little bit away from the sort of vfx
short films that we used to do you know
it's a lot more yeah
um are you kidding me though like dude
so many freaking renders this year
that's what i'm saying
we've satisfied
literally satisfied millions and
unsatisfied millions more yes
we've satisfied millions we've recreated
shots we've done it all i was actually
going to mention that because it's like
almost ironically we're the best at
visual effects we've ever been
yeah but we got all of our awards back
it doesn't come down to um it doesn't
come down to committee though it comes
down to popular vote yeah yeah and of
course zach king being at the top of the
popularity tree
right
shining breaststroke anyway i brought
that up because i've got a glass of ice
here and why is why is it just ice well
that's because the streamies actually
sent us
a bunch of these little cocktail
thingies when they do that hell yeah
brother would they do that
[Laughter]
what'd they do that for yeah so this was
i finally i wanted to drink it and i
wanted to have some context for why i'm
drinking what is that what's in there
this is a dehydrated passion fruit one
of my favorite a um
passion fruit mezcal and negroni
for you audio listeners i'm literally
holding a pouch like one of those
plastic pouches with a it's like a
nozzle on the side of it it's like it's
this
fancy cocktail ration in our dystopian
future
yeah
wait
i think you're supposed to add tequila
to that no no
no it's it's uh i smell it it's a
negroni tequila in it so negroni is made
with juice normally it's made with gin
and sweet vermouth and then like there's
maybe one or two more things in there
they're like we're gonna make a fancy
and put mescal in there i guess
hydration yeah you're gonna have to
i thought well mezcal isn't tequila but
they're derived from the same plant
might as well be wait what the heck is
the scotch of tequila space food that
looks like a freaking fruit okay
i don't know if i don't know enough
about it
you're supposed to put it in a shirt
will you try this holiday drink for us
all
merry christmas friend merry christmas
i'm gonna drink here by myself with all
of
you you're not invited
i should drink it
well because i drink the for running to
tell them what it's like yeah yeah tell
them what it's like i want it to grow in
the liquid
that's what i was hoping for
i don't know
it absorbs all the liquid is that is
that like a strength into a full passion
i mean it's it's
fruit i don't know if it's full because
that could be a double cocktail on that
oh boy i mean judging by the size of
your cup
it kind of looks like two cocktails just
gonna be see how ren's doing at the end
of this podcast wait yeah we'll track
we'll track your progress it doesn't say
serving sizes it doesn't it literally
just says passion to create it just says
enjoy so you're drinking like a couple
ounces of hard liquor
with sugar
going to be a great podcast it'll be a
great one
you're not going to have a headache you
will not have a headache
no you'll be great you'll you'll be
doing great
just wait till i get into running mode
running
yeah don't we don't want to see you on
running mode on the podcast no that's
fine i'll just i personally personally
do but
we may get into running mode on
wednesday night
we're having our annual christmas party
on a rooftop yup we're going serious
this year i don't know how this went
from
getting together to eat uh
boiled shrimp
to uh
to uh partying on a rooftop but
was there that was what 2016 or
something it was one of those years yeah
no probably 2016. that sounds right yeah
no i mean it seems like
we would fill up a whole restaurant now
with the size of our company and plus
ones so
yeah it's good we're renting a venue
it's probably cheaper this way honestly
we're gonna get and we can do whatever
we want there's no rules
that's yeah no room
yeah the laws don't apply there's no
laws there's no laws on perhaps the
sovereign
[Laughter]
resurfacing of your view
and we're sailing to an island that has
no laws and uh it's gonna be a roush's
party randa are you really gonna go on
this jetpack ride well i mean it's not
much of a jet let's not talk about that
yet i'm not ready to talk about that
did you ever go on your hot air balloon
ride no but we have uh
we have a lead
we like googled it or something pretty
sure i'm gonna you're gonna see me next
summer uh in the air let me just say
that
you have a legitimate lead on a hot air
balloon
well yeah there's a bunch that take off
in lake elmo so i'm gonna just it's true
go to lake elmo and get on a balloon wow
and then i'll be in there
what's what's the context of this ride
well it's something that's been hyped up
it was a huge announcement um
you missed the announcement yeah you
must have missed it jordan yeah but uh
yeah so hot air balloons well
i guess i might as well make a new
announcement
guys i'm going to be on a hot air
balloon potentially wow
kelly
weren't you supposed to do this while we
had some meeting or something uh the son
of a dungeon premiere
that's right things didn't shake out the
weather wasn't great so yeah oh shoot
all balloon flights
i'm serious the whole balloons were
grounded there was rain
i'm serious about doing the son of a
dungeon uh premiere next year in a
castle
in a game too
wait what
where like go to europe we'll go to a
cave legitimately or we can go to those
like like those like janky american ones
yeah like the rich hollywood elite
castles like some guy makes it some like
it's basically a personal rent fair
go to that one up in oregon you know was
it between eugene and portland there's
that that was that one castle area it's
uh you you were talking pennsylvania
yeah it's more of a theme park than a
castle isn't it isn't it a theme park a
janky castle it's pretty great
i'd highly recommend going to the
enchanted forest
i feel like
they've just claimed it they've claimed
the tunnels you're going to want to
bring a headlamp
okay to the theme park
honestly yeah
there were some head bumps don't go into
a tunnel without a helmet yeah we
learned that one yeah yeah
ren and nick learned that a few a few
weeks ago oh we won't need our helmets
this is dumb and then
two steps later did you like literally
did you lit up
the roof of that tunnel so many times
and it was like pointy rocky bits too
and i kept breaking off bits of the roof
of the tunnel and it would rain down my
back and i was getting a little
concerned that i might cause a cave in
with my head
that's really funny because i remember
specifically before you left for it that
was a topic it was hey helmets we're
gonna wear helmets as we go through
these tunnels
yeah yep
and now you didn't
now we know
yeah
like bore the tunnels wider yeah
they were made so long ago when people
were short
yeah
basically once multivitamins were
invented
yeah thank you flynn's no it's funny my
uh my great my grandmother was born in a
her her mom came over from croatia uh to
with her with my great grandfather to
run a boarding house for minors
and uh they would sleep
uh
in they had three shifts so every eight
hours there'd be a new person in the bed
and they had and they had the beds like
the beds were shorter because people
weren't as tall so
they would have to that was like her job
growing up because they had to just they
just
grow beds laundry cooked no like it was
just they ran the boarding house
for all the iron ore miners that worked
there wow
that's crazy if you were a tall person
would they bring out like a
one of those like helmet
you know
it's a misconception though that all
people were shorter back in history
there's people weren't
actually like are you kidding me shorter
you were just malnourished have you ever
been to like
micro no
if you're if you're nourished like if
you go to like any or i mean europe i'm
just saying it's a misconception people
think maybe that everyone was shorter
back in the day have you ever met a
dutch dude those guys there's not a
single dutch person in existence shorter
than two meters well not like six now in
our century
not in our century
but like i remember going to like the
east coast to like little parts of
boston and you like you go through the
little parts yeah it's like it's like
the shire
like but i'm serious like i've seen some
small ass doors
there are small doors
[Laughter]
i think i think we're so used to doors
that perfectly match our height that we
don't like the idea of people like oh
it's just normal for us to duck when we
go through i mean what would the reason
for a small door be other than because
you're short i mean i don't know less
material
the door is the quintessential absence
of materials like the bigger the door
the better really
it's like we're running out of wood like
make the door bigger
it's less
material i mean i guess i see i see you
need a door to fill that space
and we had to make the doors they're no
longer eight feet they're now six feet
sorry
yeah everyone's just gonna have to deal
with it
it's uh
definitely yeah everyone was four feet
jan says there's another misconception
about how you people used to walk he
says that people don't walk the same now
that they did back in the day
he says that people used to walk on
their toes
hey
hey let me tell you a tale about
storyblocks today's podcast sponsor once
upon a time there was a little video
creator he was in the woods all alone
and he didn't have anyone to help him
make his videos it would take him all
day and all night and weeks and weeks on
end and he would sit there and craft out
all the little moments of his video
instead of focusing on the things that
really made his video unique and special
he spent the majority of his time
getting b-roll and getting stock images
and creating motion graphics templates
just so that he could like have smooth
transitions in his video and one day a
little fairy godmother came out of the
woods and told him about a little
website called storyblocks he was amazed
because he discovered that storyblocks
was the one-stop shop for all of his
stock asset needs he could just go to
storyblocks and he could download as
much as he needed in high quality 4k and
use it in whatever projects he wanted
because he had an unlimited all-access
plan and with his unlimited all-access
plan he had access to a virtually
unlimited library images and b-roll and
audio assets and more that was
constantly being refreshed that he could
return to any time he needed he started
pumping out videos and then he hired
little little elves to help him in the
tree edit all the videos together and
before you knew it he was a successful
professional video creator what did we
learn from this little christmas story
about the elves we learned that don't go
into the woods alone without a stock
asset platform we use story blocks here
at corridor we use it all the time and
you could too all you got to do is head
on over to
storyblocks.comcast to get started and
that's exactly what you're gonna get and
hey if you're part of a team talk to
your team leader about an enterprise
plan maybe you're one of the elves in
santa's workshop and santa hasn't
realized yet that there's a whole
platform that all of his elves can use
i'm sure he's got a video department up
there i mean how do you think all the
christmas movies get made have a great
holiday and um head on over to
storybox.com if you're uh if you're
interested thanks to them for sponsoring
now back to the podcast
yeah it's actually true they're barefoot
it's actually true
like in the forest
and your ankle is supposed to actually
act like a a shock absorber so you land
on the ball of your feet and your ankles
kind of absorb some of that impact so
in the before times people used to run
around and walk around on their
tippy-toes so did they all have ripped
calves or what oh yeah why not probably
there's actually some videos on youtube
about like how medieval people walked
it's very interesting it's the entire
fundamental basis of the company five
finger vibrams you know those like
gloves oh the glitter yeah
yeah the ones that wrap around your toes
individually well you've seen those
drawings those are like people from the
17th and 18th century like they have
like those they're all strutting around
but they've got the heels you know on
their like little toe shoes
is that why they invented heels
uh what to keep the dream alive
that's not a boot heel because people
were used to walking like that so when
they started wearing shoes that was a
natural way i don't know if they kept
their heel up that high i mean if you if
you have a heel on your shoe that's like
a two inches it's like you're gonna
use those balls to your feet
all right yeah if i gotta heal i'm gonna
use it we're total experts in this
category
i was just pointing out another another
thing that's about people of the past
that i don't know if it's true or not we
should make a podcast
[Laughter]
be huge yeah
but they lack no i mean like i was like
when i went to the met like uh earlier
this year i saw some big ass armor dude
like there was some big chunky armor and
it was like there's also short person
armor but it was for like the teenager
kings yeah but like there were some big
mofos
walking around armor there's there are
two people inside that set of armor
but also you know it's like you have to
twist your best fighters you know you
give them feasts so they can grow
you know like you have the elite
huge people who get a little extra fears
[Laughter]
grows more
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that's probably history
makes sense
just read the first line of wikipedia
articles
any like notes on this history you know
to further improve it
oh my gosh that's amazing
history that's it right there we're done
we're done shut it off yeah
there's that's next year's green light
when is when is this podcast supposed to
come out
uh the day before christmas two days
before the day before 23rd
crispness
how is uh how is crunch miss going for
everybody oh man it's going great yeah
so he's loving it yeah you know this
year's pretty
i mean
we were kind of joking no i mean it's
it's fine i mean
the crew front it's it's okay yeah no uh
jordan and i are mostly just joking
because like these next three days
aren't really that busy for us but the
last few weeks have been very busy yeah
you guys have been on a tear the last
few weeks yeah it's like the whole last
month honestly the whole last half year
for me was incredibly busy
yeah one week after another man but yeah
this week we don't have a video coming
out so you guys are just like oh what do
i do yeah i've basically just been
wandering upstairs in a robe asking
people what they're doing
that's my crunch
are you wearing one of those creator
burnout robes he was he totally was
good it's very comfortable yeah you
don't want to get burned out every now
and then you got to put one of those on
just to make sure that you put that on
and sit on the therapy chair up there
and just i saw you you reclined it oh
yeah oh yeah you gotta be
melt into nick's therapy chair
nick i should get you one of those signs
that lucy has from peanuts that's like
psychiatry help five cents and then
people can sit in your chair yeah and
talk to you no yeah for sure i have a a
new chair of a new like chill zone near
my desk you could put it it's a special
place it's all very special yeah it's
like a third put a head tickler there
put a little scallop ticklers
you and dean have sort of invented the
art of chill in the studio oh dude we
have a carpet i'm gonna get some plants
next year meanwhile i'm still using a
door as a desk yep you are using a
door's desk and you still have the
post-it note that says don't clean my
desk yeah the carmichael put on his
actual desk before it got turned into
and then jake cut it in half
it's the funniest thing
it's still there i haven't touched it
it's been there for years
that thing is historic at this point it
is sustainable that's real history
that's not probably history you know i'm
over here being like i kind of want to
get a one of those motorized standing
desks where the entire desk just goes up
and down i have one at home and it's the
best thing ever yeah i agree
you just press a button yeah you and
it's got like presets you press a button
it goes up to that preset level
you can get any desk you want
oh my gosh your posture will be so good
like no so 17th century shoes with like
the one big buckle on it yep yeah which
is what was the buckle for what are they
what are they strapping in i don't
heelys i don't know
was that to keep the shoe tight
i guess so it must have been there just
one big strap
one who can make up the most plausible
like definition dude who's gonna who's
gonna make the first healey's
high-heeled healies
need to make a proper comeback
they're special especially in target i
got back into these a year they should
go remember that sam yeah i was like
really in the heels there for a minute
and trying to learn how to use them and
then you guys are like moving the desk
around or something like that and i was
sliding over to and i slipped out and i
totally like hit the desk with both of
my shins so hard the whole desk like
jumped up in the air
and then i still have like an
indentation in my chin years later there
used to be some that had that had actual
roller blades that would come out do you
remember those ones yeah they would pop
out they'd actually pop out and they
were
and he jumped up for a rebound and they
all came out they popped out
and he landed and just immediately
biffed and he never got him again i
think he was going to land and then just
like rolled away
james
they were super so like all my friends
had healeys they were all the rage and
i'm like mom dad i really just want
healies for christmas that's all i
wanted
and they got me what they thought were
heelys and they were these big wide
shoes that would look like platform
shoes
they had these like you could like get
there's a button and you have to like
jam the button down and then it pops out
the wheels and then you have to open the
wheels but it's like this whole process
so my friends would frickin just zoom
away
and i'd sit down and i'd be like
and i was like this little weak 10 year
old sex like push the button in and then
like trying to get it and then they're
like these fat wheels it was not as cool
this might be the same ones wait do you
guys remember soaps soaps the shoot the
shoes with the grinding railings yeah
soaps
yeah
i was gonna say what happened to those
tricks
just
so weird grind it
you could run up to rails and then jump
and slide down the road so many tubular
so many kids got hurt with those because
you have to land and you still have all
that velocity then you just have to do a
sprint when you land and not eat it
it's so funny just asking for it you
know what we need we need to give
children a way to grind on things
just that sentence is awful
let's give them soaps
just give them soaps guys let's get
everybody in the studio soaps and see
what happens even the name yes we can
install grinding rails along every path
in the studio so we can just go ahead
and i mean i'm kind of not opposed to
that the bell rings for school and
everyone just hops on our radar
from studio three all the way down to
studio four perfect man don't threaten
me with a good time
that sounds great
friend would be down you would figure
that out
sure i i mean i would i would have
believed right
what someone else figured out
all right so uh i i have some news it's
not huge news but
um over the weekend i got a dog
oh what what i did well what kind of dog
do you get
uh it's a
it's a cattle dog
um
so it's a cow cattle dog no um
it's it's hard to explain so
it's a sheep there's a there's a dog
here called the texas cattle dog but it
isn't really a breed it's like a mutt
between two australian cattle dog breeds
um one being the australian shepherd and
the other being the australian cattle
dog and they're just kind of like
working dogs and they're they're all
over oh that's a nice looking dog
yeah okay sure yeah
and so this one's kind of a butt this
one's kind of a mutt between that and
then what we think is like
a little bit border collie
because she's black and white
um and her ears aren't straight up like
that they're like half oh watercolors
are supposed to be like the smartest
dogs in the world right yeah she's so
far uh shown to be that she's pretty
smart um we got her from the pound she's
two
um and she's really good personality um
no one no one took the time to train her
anything oh man
so i've been doing that um
and actually over just working with her
yesterday and then this morning she can
already sit and stay and then come when
called
nice
but uh i i don't know how this dog
i don't know where this dog came from
like they said it was a stray
but uh it uh
yeah i couldn't like she's two years old
she doesn't know how to sit
well
but she's smart imagine that all the
time yeah
like sleeping awful
just not knowing what to do
yeah just have really strong legs now
having to lean up against the wall
you wouldn't believe how strong her legs
are
she fell asleep last night standing in
there yes like a bless her heart just go
from his hands
i bet she was thrilled though the first
time the dog over into bed
i've become more and more convinced that
the two dogs that i got a couple years
ago are idiots
they're so dumb dude
one of your dogs what kind of dog
uh which sorry what are their names
again there's gizmo and ace dude so i
think it was ace ace is the little black
one jenna was like holding him and i was
like petting him and he's so nice he's
like oh and then
in an instant he went like he went a
freaking angry billboard on me yeah and
i bite you tried to bite me dude that's
gizmo gizmo
he's larger dude it was like it went
from zero to 11. yeah so fast
it was a straight up demonic
that's a great reference yeah demonic
billboard like he's been both jan and
wes before and it's like it's it's now a
thing it's not a thing we have to keep
him secluded from other people until
they get used to him he's just figured
out until he gets used to them yeah yeah
but he's also like the sweetest dog ever
he just wants nothing but love and like
he's happiest when he's literally like
resting on your chest with his head just
like looking up at you
and that's his happiest time
but then he also will try to bite
everyone
so um
yeah i've been struggling with the last
two years of teaching anything are those
poodles or what kind are they they're
they're some sort of poodle mix with uh
like i don't even know if you'll never
remember a cocker spaniel and a terrier
vicious tendencies i've noticed like
well
i don't know it's uh i mean yeah they
can because poodles in general are very
smart like obi was very smart he was he
was a smart dog and he was like a mini
poodle um
or anything like that
they also lived on the streets for years
can't can't take the street out of the
dog
yeah well the terrier the terrier mixed
with the street life is probably what's
happening there
um terriers are kind of like that
poodles obviously yeah they were used
for french bird like waterfowl hunting
yeah
um they don't shed
that's exactly i mean that's the main
thing for us is that you know jenna's uh
allergic oh wow so we had to get the
hypoallergenic so they have hair instead
of fur and they don't they don't shed
it's not great yeah but then you have to
give them haircuts and baths all the
time
yeah is he protective of the house
yeah
they're very they're territorial yeah
very how does that work here the dogs
are terrier
terrier
like when we got like a mop yeah no like
i'm not even kidding like have you ever
seen that video or that the picture do
you ever see the picture of that sheep
in new zealand that escaped and lived in
a cave for like a decade no and then
they finally found him and he was
literally just a giant ball of wool
and
you can't he couldn't even see because
his there was so much fur on his face
that it closed up around his eyes so he
was kind of blind have we just
domesticated them so much that now they
don't have like so oh my gosh she looks
like a meatball
before humans were like yeah
farming sheep how how did that i mean
just
just as an image
that's the escapee sheep from new
zealand they look like a guy looks like
a lion
the longest wool jacket just the
thickest one
they look like hard oh yeah that's hard
it looks like
you hit it with a baseball bat and like
the bat never gets to the sheep because
the hair is so thick
so that's how my dogs looked when uh
they were found and rescued okay
we didn't we didn't clean them up after
that someone else had rescued them
cleaned them up and had them up for
adoption for like two straight months
but
no one took them until we did well they
named them they named them shrek shrek
the sheep who escaped shearing for six
years
who escaped
i mean
they found his master plan in his cell
yeah these pictures she just was like
don't look at me
still about please stop taking pictures
all my brothers and sisters are shaved
[Laughter]
yeah i think uh i think she has just
been
been with me
that's why they're truly domesticated is
that they wouldn't they can't survive
without us they get too hairy
yeah and then they people get out
yeah yeah that's crazy
like that's speaking of history it's
like yeah like a couple hundred years
ago maybe a couple thousand years ago
some guy was just like dude this
animal's hair just does not stop
and it's so warm
he's like we should make more of these
sheep come over here he just found a
tribe of sheep and they're all being
smothered by themselves it's like oh you
got one of those like new sheep that
gets really huge
balls of hair here
selective breeding is actually like a
legit thing and it happens quick russia
someone in russia did this experiment
years ago with foxes where they
selectively bred out
any of the sort of wild tendencies of
these foxes they would basically take
just the offspring that were the nicest
ones and breed just those and it was
something like within six generations
the the foxes were like dogs they were
just like happy they would come up to
people like no big deal and there were
secondary things that were
wildly shocking for me at least their
ears became floppy
yeah like what like
flop you always think of dogs with like
floppy ears and whatnot but you think of
foxes and they've got like the really
sharp pointy ears because they got to
listen to danger and after just
literally six or seven generations
all of that aggressiveness had been like
bred out of them along with the sharp
ears it was wild that could have just
been like a bonus
genetics
it was probably purely it's like he's
happy his ears are a little weird but
we're looking for the happiness and then
they yeah no i think that's the thing
with that's that's consistent with dogs
too that's that's why dog most dog
breeds their ears are down like that
what if what if they did that with
people so everyone was like really happy
all right
are you ready for a quick history of
domestic sheep
is this probably history or real history
this is wikipedia history so it's called
history this is this is most likely
history this is
most likely history that's fantastic
history from concentrate it's just the
history of domestic sheep goes back
about 10 000 years to about 10 000 bc
sorry so 12 000 years
domestication domestication of the wild
muflon in ancient mesopotamia
um so that's the mufan i'm looking at it
here it's still around today uh it is uh
it's basically a ram it looks like a
ramp there's nothing quite like
you know
freaking humanity spends thousands of
years evolving to be like
hairless
and then they just go after animals with
more hair i know we could have solved
that problem like what's going on by
just keeping our own hair like
not having to make fluids
eat the sheep too you can't do a purpose
yeah uh what is what is a
sheep meat called
meat i guess the genetic buttons that's
the word yeah the advantage we get as
humans is we can take our hair off
whenever we walk yeah that's true
so you want to swim take off
your hair yep
i mean it's one of my top 10 things
about being a human
go swimming you're super hairy
if you're like
weighing
me but this says the domestication of
dogs could have occurred as
long as 20 to 40 000 years ago
i believe that yeah so same with cats
man but
did you know that okay here's a fun
here's a fun fact that's probably
history
the house cat is actually not
like bred from larger cats
it's there's there's certain wildcats
that are actually only a slightly larger
than
house cats that house cats are that's
yeah but even smaller than that even
smaller than bobcats yeah
there's and there's some that are still
around today
even smaller than that
like slightly larger than a house cat
and uh just with a little longer legs
they're still around did they like walk
along like boulders and see like a
little rock on the boulder and be like
and knock it off probably probably
probably
ancient egyptians using laser pointers
yeah yeah yeah yeah they'd probably like
well they'd have little prisms that
would reflect the sunlight right yeah
the ancient egyptians would get loot
drops from the aliens
that's why they built the pyramids like
loot drop right here please
well the ufos won't fly very low
[Laughter]
around the pyramid
all around the whole base of the pyramid
was just a row of
[Laughter]
buckets i've seen drawings that no
that's true
it's depicted in the uh
hieroglyphics yeah yeah it's probably
true i remember it
[Laughter]
yeah my friend went there and he said
that they had dug up a few buckets from
the sand
next to the
next to the pyramids
that's amazing that's still a laser
point
only the rarest of rare loot drop
buckets would get buried with the
pharaohs
right
yeah
that's actually why this is why they
started digging them up in the first
place because they were like gotta get
that loot the word got out
word got out
yeah
they started digging them up that's not
nobody's grinding over here
i'm super excited to um
have a dog again it's gonna be fun
that's awesome that's really cool i'm
excited
you've got at least a small yard
yeah there's definitely some room for
her to get out and about and learn some
stuff and maybe we'll get her in a video
at some point who knows
what did you name this dog
yeah uh her name's alamo
alabama
[Laughter]
this
that's why we did it
yeah makes sense
yeah so
it's got some training to do
she learned quick though i started with
just some basic stuff yesterday and she
likes mel skins
yeah i mean so nice she's already
figuring that out but she already found
like there's my yard is fenced and she
already found three openings in the
fence snuck under two of them
so tests your security from the inside
oh yeah exactly she's like the you know
the programmer that you hired the
ethical hacker the white
red team yes
yep that's so cool
so yeah doing that
that's cool
yeah what are you guys doing for the
holidays
man i'm sticking around in town actually
oh you're like
gonna be one of three people
everyone it's so weird everyone leaves
l.a during during the holidays it's kind
of yeah it's kind of a nice time of year
to be in town actually it's quiet yeah
i'm looking forward to just kind of like
hanging out getting better at cinema 4d
and just
relaxing
a little bit of learning time huh yeah
yeah yeah i'm looking forward to just
like working on some random little
projects here and there just to kind of
get better at things nice man
i want to experiment more with ambergen
dude me too
me too
that seems so cool yeah it's super super
red
man
my goal is to not work at all
if i cannot work at all
so happy see i don't consider that work
i consider that play yeah but only if
it's actually foreplay
but it's been doubling down to god
in this four-player
interesting
firearm
and you press a button
real-time
[Laughter]
to figure out some things about the
program
oh man as you load up your fluid
i'll go with you
naughty vfx though so are you going to
see it
i am yeah i'm going to drive up though
i'm doing the right nice perfect good
i'm glad i'm glad i don't get like my
mom's been calling me every day she's
like
i hope there's not a snowstorm make sure
there's not a snowstorm oh you'll be
totally fine in a snowstorm really oh
yeah easy especially because you've got
all-wheel drive without change yeah see
that's what i keep telling i'm like mom
don't worry you don't need chains on
like an interstate
up over the past in southern oregon if
it is actually legit snowy
you kind of need i so i was driving home
from seattle last year and it was
through that pass in southern oregon
they're like
south of ashland yeah and it started
snowing and i i definitely slid across
the lane at one point it was scary i'm
going to be a gun
i was going like 20 miles an hour it was
slow everyone was going slow oh my gosh
it was it was easily the most tense
moment of that entire drive jesus
but i only i only had
and front-wheel drive especially because
uh those electric motors they're able to
actually measure the torque on each
motor or the traction a thousand times a
second and modulate if if the front tire
starts losing traction it instantly cuts
the power to it and increases the torque
on the back
and by the time you get to the next uh
to when you get to that slick spot that
it detected on the front wheels the back
wheels have deactivated and the front
wheels have reactivated
thousand times a second with nuts
yeah electricity that's awesome i'm
gonna link my mom to this podcast so
she's gonna rest usually yeah but i'll
probably be up there by the way skip
through the history stuff yeah this is
one part
she'll get pissed off at all that
um no it's yeah man i'm going up there
it's going to be
really nice just hopefully hanging out
absorbing winter vibes you know that is
the nice part about leaving yeah is that
actually feels like yeah exactly exactly
you know what about you are you
nothing i'm staying here i'm staying
here i'm chilling out dude we should
play some basketball i'm so down for
that dude i'm sorry i wanna i wanna like
we've been talking you dean and i have
been talking about playing some
basketball you need to hoop it up don't
worry maybe christmas when you do it
yeah
these are safe it's the other ones
whatever those are right and no soap's
allowed on the court
now
i used to have those shoes that would
train you to jump higher or like this
because they basically had platform they
were platform they're they were inverse
high heels they were high balls high
balls yeah
yeah it was basically you'd have like a
two inch platform underneath your toes
essentially and your heels wouldn't have
anything below them they were just
hovering in the air and so as you did
your exercises and stuff like that you
would train your calves to be stronger i
guess yeah
buff calves i took them on a cruise i
went on with my family and me and my
brother spent all our time training
[Laughter]
i still have the nba dream alive in my
soul
yeah thanks jump souls for ruining my
cruises
oh man i can i can just picture that
yeah my cows are tasty though by the end
of it i'll tell you whether older or
younger older 18 months older okay yeah
okay so so we were pursuing the mba
together
you know yeah yeah there's some really
weird looking ones did you have these
crazy ones no mine were like they were
like franken boots on the front or these
big things diy i made them oh you just
put like strapped weights to your tongue
no not weights i i took like you know
like uh in the gym you have like really
thick foam padding i just cut up a bunch
of those in the shape of the bottom part
of my foot and i wear your phone duct
taped them to my shoe where'd you get
the phone
yeah
gym padding like this like wait what is
it yeah
is there something wrong with your legs
it looks like they're like the jump
souls v5 they look like free ships you
just had like bone surgeries or
something
or you're like going through physical
therapy and relearning the walk oh dude
youth as you were making those kinds of
mistakes
you got that i spent my money on it you
got these guys
attachments to where but why did you get
them again to make the mba sam you
wanted to be better at basketball yeah
the only thing that was holding me back
was my calves and then you were like
you're like
yeah we're going on a cruise soon and
you look at all the stuff you could pack
and you're like should i drive
i only have limited space let me stuff
these
did you like bring a basketball too no
didn't bring a basketball it was kind of
just hoping they'd have your whole plan
to get into the nba was twitch
literally i'm just telling you abs held
me back i mean it's a great conversation
it's like what's wrong with your shoes
like
training
for the nba
i've got dreams of joining the nba
as i walk through the dining room with
[Laughter]
[Applause]
is just a ride to southeastern europe so
i can join some of the leagues there
yeah that's all this is everything i'm
doing is just like a small distraction
wow why did i do that i don't know
that's it was a really good story
do you have any pictures of this
guy
they look like they look like tourist
sandals that are just far too big they
look like just you
just wearing it on the beach
everyone literally i guess is going to
be so upset
yeah people need to know oh my god yeah
oh my goodness
this is the part in the video podcast
where the the image actually pops up of
what we're looking at right now
i'll tell you what if they ever make
jump souls with heelys in them oh i'm
first in line
all right
that's really good oh that's really good
that's yeah so i've always i've never
been on a cruise before i'm i'm kind of
terrified of it like hey you're on the
ship
and you're going to be there for what a
week oh yeah
yeah like they take you through a little
like you know how before you get on an
airplane they go through like the flight
safety instruction when you onboard
after that then everyone has to come out
and then the captain like addresses
everybody and tells you what to do in an
emergency and stuff does it like titanic
rules still yeah everywhere yeah it's
like it's like fight women and children
only and then everyone else dies and no
no for real yeah you go you go on and
you all stand on the deck or wherever
outside and then
everyone lines up and there's a huge
announcement they're like
you're on my boat these are my rules
yeah
get drunk and then
then they go like all right
you know let her rip
yeah that's basically accurate yeah that
is pretty much what they say yeah no
that's the nautical term right
let it rip yeah let it rip on the
starboard side
i mean your majesty's navy they're
pretty great yeah it's like food and
rest i did that for my bachelor party it
was dope yeah i was about to say jake
had a different
experience
despite what happened at the end it's
still one of the best trips i've ever
been on it was an amazing fact that that
almost that almost makes it like you
know that's the icing on the cake the
peak they got attacked by a radar dish
the fish yeah the finale
was amazing it was amazing actually i'm
gonna have to explain that one i don't
well can i explain the story since i
wasn't there
give it give us the problem we start
with a little context probably no
context no because we can't have any
primary sources for problems history
okay uh shooting guns at each other
we're playing tt with nerf guns
all right guns we snuck out a bunch of
firearms onto the under the ship nerf
guns having some friendly
non-lethal round fire back and forth and
jake again i wasn't there so i know
exactly what happened jake wanted to get
an extra vantage point so he climbed up
the side of like the top bit that you're
not supposed to give him way too much
credit i don't think there's really a
reason why he got upset literally
and he got up on the top and looked down
and was gonna snipe a guy but you know
those radar dishes are basically long
logs that are spinning they're like
giant huge couches and he got hit in the
back and thrown over the side and landed
you know 800 feet down onto the platform
the funniest part for me anyways was how
people reacted to it
because
the the the detail was that
clint and dee oh my god
underneath jake when it happened so jake
climbs this thing gets whacked by this
massive like unstoppable force
and it gets it's it was more like it was
like 15 feet the captain's like maybe
what the heck just happened to me
there's a mountain in front of us what
just happened but dna
20 is pretty 20 is like the height of
the ceiling in studio four i don't know
yeah yeah it's it couldn't have been
that it was it was it was 12 to 15 feet
but yeah jake gets whacked he he gets
thrown
like basically head first down towards
the ground and dee and clint are there
and they have the first reactions and
dee's reaction is pretty standard he
kind of like reaches out
with his arms and just kind of breaks
jake's ball with his wrists basically
which proceeds to make it so now he's
got like sprained wrists
for like the next two days but then
clint
does the best best thing ever which is
you know like when you drop your phone
and like you like kind of like
you kind of like breakfast
clint basically just kind of puts his
toe up
he's trying to hacky sack jake he just
kind of puts his toe out and she just
crashes
into his foot
did you have a visual on that sam did
you have visual on that when it happened
or is that yeah i saw it happen i saw it
happen and then clint uh yeah then clint
basically ends up having a sprained
ankle
for like the next few hours
because of this as well
and then uh jake was like knocked out
for like probably about 10 seconds oh
wait yeah man yeah you went out you
blacked out on it you got you you had to
get stitches didn't you
yeah on my chin you got some stitches
did anybody ask you any questions about
what you were doing up there yeah they
came up they came up and and the guys
grabbed them and then i was like nobody
touched me we'll just leave it like this
because that way no one's implicated
i'll tell them i it was all my idea
which it was and then they came up and
checked me out and then once they made
sure that my neck wasn't broken they
they brought me down to the uh infirmary
the medical bay
yeah and then they had me they had me
they had me sign a bunch of release
waivers and stitched me up and said
[ __ ] off
were any of those ndas because it was so
valuable
no no i don't think so
we've done a little video about this
before that's amazing cctv yeah and then
probably from multiple angles of this
happening oh yeah probably so like by
the time it's all said and done it's
like 3 a.m
and uh yeah we capped that night off
with 20 pastrami sandwiches reuben's
and 20 apple juices
then they bring this huge cart of room
service down with 20
20 of these things how many of you were
there
well like we ordered extra ones but like
we realized that the room service was
free and they also like previously we've
been like going we'd call on one room
and get five
and then go on another one call five and
then we realized that no one gave a [ __ ]
by the end
[Laughter]
i know a guy in in the in the kitchen
he'll bring us down 20.
he's got reuben that's too much pastrami
it's like that's yeah wow we have come a
long way we went from freaking sailors
eating hard tack with maggots in it to
bring 20 rubens
and apple juice and 20 apple juice
because there was no more alcohol being
served
not to you guys they're like these guys
are cut off dude
yeah
oh my god yeah i remember also hearing
that there's like this kind of like
like standoff of like all right
we're not gonna we're not gonna get
angry at you for you know
hitting our
our radar dish as long as you don't get
angry at us for getting hurt that was
basically even though that's just kind
of a yeah jake's like oh i might sue
they're like oh hey
would 20 pastrami sandwiches
after i was all fixed up they had a
lawyer in there and they were like yeah
so wow
the ship's lawyer we'll just both walk
away from this
built-in
a lawyer on your ship when you have that
many crazy people it's like it's kind of
like you're serious a lawyer entertainer
on in the container yeah they also still
have a sergeant at arms who's like the
you know
the enforcer yeah yeah
he came up with a short sword
for real holy crap
i want to believe let me believe
i
[Laughter]
yeah
oh yeah you gotta have a sergeant he
came up in his like undies and
everything too yeah
yeah so yeah cruises are great
i've never been on a cruise
we should go we should all go it would
be a lot of fun if like we took the
whole company it would be like 50 people
how many pastrami sandwiches there's 15
people it's like that's a lot of
pastrami dude yeah yeah surprised they
didn't ask any questions
dude you get like 150 pastrami
sandwiches yeah yeah yeah you start
doing the math you realize there's a lot
of imagine how tall we'll grow yeah
imagine this
well i'll be like seven foot three to
get numb
just full of pastrami in our boat we'll
leave our jumpsuits behind because we
don't need them anymore
i didn't know about the pastrami hack if
i knew about the hack i would have been
in the nba by now but under our medieval
theory you should have easily made it oh
i know i wasn't eating enough yeah you
could have
zombies 2019. we'll have to pay the
contractors to enlarge our doors ahead
of schedule
[Laughter]
make sure the loading dock is clear
yeah make sure the loading door is open
[Laughter]
we got soaps
yeah
dream of reality
yeah reality
where's a good place to cruise where do
you guys cruise alice
alaska that's
yeah that one's cool it's like basically
three days it's like a day and a half
you go down there you chill at port and
walk around in the city
atving and stuff is great nice and then
yeah a day and a half back pretty chill
that's where the chicken spinner came
from too that's where the chicken
spinners came from yeah because they
they they have you know the the martial
jake
was basically like a god he just walked
in and everyone was like swung in the
chair what's up and he's like yo
i'll take some of those
you're gonna have to explain
yeah so there's all these market sellers
that like you know yeah get the people
that are coming on and off the ships
right
yeah so they bring their they bring all
their goods you know they're like
handcrafted goods all the wares for sale
and so i was just buying a lot because i
was i was buying stuff for like my wife
and i was buying stuff for my
mother-in-law and
and then the chicken spinners came along
and this guy had this thing where it
just spins and the chickens just their
heads go up and down and i was like well
i gotta have that um
so i got a real chicken i was imagining
like a butcher like a chicken seller
with like rotisserie chickens exactly
it's like
it's like a wheel on a rod and you spin
around and all the chickens
the chickens come to life and it's not
that loud
oh these are the same chicken spinners
we had in son of a dungeon right no no
that was the
that was a mistake
that was an artist's interpretation of
it wasn't a true chicken spinner yeah
that wasn't a true chicken spinner so
and then i had just i had won some money
playing blackjack too so
i was just like buying everything and
then once they saw that i was buying
stuff like a bunch of other people just
swarmed me and then i was like cracking
jokes with the kids and like playing and
they had a football
bag
and it was it was just
yeah yeah he nailed it i
i think i'm more confused as to what a
chicken spinner is now though that's
fine that's just yeah you know one day
we'll find one yeah
maybe you'll have to come on the cruise
and we'll we'll find out the only way
yeah it's the only way jake can
introduce us to his friends down there
yeah we went to papas and beer the bar
and things some people get very rowdy
there it's kind of an anything goes type
place and i was sitting there like with
the chicken spinner in the middle of the
bar just spinning it around and there's
like you know
just everyone loved it of course
everyone was stoked probably yeah there
were some things going on around us that
were it was like tortuga you know it was
like
pirates of the caribbean when they go to
tortuga and there's like guys fighting
and there's naked women and there's like
chaos
yeah yeah the guys like punching each
other falling off the balcony exactly
yeah that's a card table okay cool great
chickens that's what's up
also we invented a bucket of beers
it's a paddle and then
[Laughter]
yeah it's like hungry hungry hippos on a
paddle
but without okay that's not what i was
imagining so you spin it in the little
weight like animates the chicken and i
just imagine jake sitting in the middle
of a freaking pirate bar
yeah everyone's like
down and that's basically what it was
and we were just we were just chilling
in a corner just kind of taking it all
in and
chicken spinners and beer and that's
very intense
yeah it was fun
wow yeah i'm glad i didn't die
yeah are you going anywhere the holiday
yeah going out to the midwest oh nice
gonna get into some snow action kind of
nice it's really snowy out there right
now so it's gonna be pretty exciting
it's pretty cold
i hope to do some snowboarding next year
i really want to go snowboarding again
it's been a while
there's not much snow in l.a
i mean there's some snow in are you know
in washington are you yeah
maybe but very unlikely okay
next year
yeah it's gonna be great
yep my brother's coming down from p.a
from lancaster pa
it's gonna be a good time very nice are
you guys gonna do a foot race
a dude his his wife george ann
my sister-in-law she could smoke me now
like she just ran
a
246 marathon
wait seriously she's 146 kilometers no
like about inches like some three hours
yeah six minutes six minute miles for 26
months okay that's really absolutely
ridiculous yeah she just did that last
weekend
holy smokes are there like special shoes
that
[Laughter]
but they're inverted it's just the toe
side has the shoe
strap but you are being serious about
the marathon part yeah i'm being serious
that's insane phenomenal wow yeah good
for her man yeah so you're both a shame
yeah that's that's legit nuts she is man
i
i mean my brother did a marathon he did
like a 215 marathon he or something
really fast but we
yeah just doing a marathon alone is
mind-blowing to me
let alone averaging
better than i've ever done on any single
my dad started doing marathons in his
late 30s and he did a marathon on his
40th birthday
wow he he was able to wear like this
jersey saying i'm turning 40 today and
i'm still running marathons or i forget
what it was some sort of like clever
little pun or something i forget he got
on the news it was great it was the
houston marathon
oh nice in the year 2000
[Music]
nice awesome y2k
feels like only yesterday
were any of you nervous for y2k
no i have memories of going to costco
and my family was like buying all this
water and batteries and stuff so there
was some fear there walks clocks
clocks that wouldn't go wrong
i remember waking up on the morning of
y2k and i walk downstairs and my dad's
watching the new year in
must have been like
japan
or hong kong and and he was like yeah
look everything's still fine
yeah
i was like
oh okay
but he was yeah he was a skeptic the y2k
bug it's one of those things where it's
like it was going to be a problem except
for the fact that a whole ton of
software engineers worked their butt off
for like a year to make sure it would
wasn't going to be a problem right so
it's like the media since sensing
well sensational
sensationalism actually helped the
problem as well as fueling the fire yeah
dude but now everyone's like everyone
just remembers it not being a big deal
because they solved it yeah
the issue was what the the clock the men
and the blacks it was like a weird
cataloging thing in software and i i
honestly do not remember the details of
of the problem at all but it was it had
to do with some sort of weird sort of
indexing problem with housing the
current so the problem is that it could
have bankrupted the entire banking
system
yeah um because of interest that was the
that was taken to the extreme is that if
it resets to zero from nine nine
then
that it stops tracking
interest and like
monetary inventory and then
it's
it's gone you lost like no one thought
we'd make it that far so that yeah
yeah yeah
it would have taken like trillions and
trillions and trillions of dollars out
of the economy which would have like
eventually caused like a you know you
can't do that because then the credit
system collapses and then everything
else collapses
yeah that was more understandably
terrifying than i
expected
yeah
i thought it was bugs when i was i was
like yeah i was very young you thought
it was the white kid saying that there's
bugs
[Laughter]
bugs are coming and they're right on
time the bugs came out of the internet
tubes and started it amazing
no man yeah very
very small memories of that
it's so funny yeah
well christ has affected everyone
that's right
a lot of a lot of hard-working people
doing stuff that you don't even know
they're doing to make the world go
around that's a whole thing it's a real
thing just like us the real heroes just
like
it wasn't for this podcast
how would you
how would we know what happened in the
history
ladies and gentlemen thank you for
listening probably
probably history uh with the corridor
cast
we hope you enjoyed this episode and uh
we hope you have a great holiday and uh
shout out to my smaller ancient peoples
yes
shout out to all the smalls out there
hope you're getting on them
our ancient smalls yeah yeah
now we're done
small people big buckets
you have to catch it if you find
yourself with a loot bucket in your hand
uh let us know in the comments we we're
interested in seeing those ancient
egyptian loot buckets dude we should do
more probably history
happy holidays
always wear a helmet and low ceiling
spaces merry christmas eve eve and merry
christmas eve
yep
don't let your dreams be dreams don't
you that's crazy dreams this christmas
just do it
after christmas after christmas boxing
day
save all your big plans for the 26th
boxing day it's a british
ready ready ren final one of the year oh
boy this is the final one three singing
final one three three two two
one